[Music]
I've said it before but one of the most
amazing things in the world today is how
we are all truly connected instantly if
something happens in France or Egypt or
Iceland people across the globe hear
about it as quickly as the people of
France or Egypt or Iceland as you guys
know I think there are real risks in our
endlessly connected world just see my
direct message from last week but
without question our ability to break
down Geographic barriers connect with
people from other cultures and Sharon
ideas being formed across the globe is
an incredibly impactful advancement for
humanity of course this connectivity
this hearing about and seeing new people
and fresh ideas is only part of the
puzzle new people and fresh ideas only
matter if you learn from them for the
better or for the worse so when we see
change like in the Egyptian revolution
in Tahrir Square in 2011 with people
fighting against an oppressive regime it
only truly matters to us if it changes
our behavior and our understanding of
the world if you just use a hashtag
instead of understanding why the
revolution happened or why an arguably
worse regime came in right after it or
why your regime just like the first one
came in after that then you really
aren't doing anything other than adding
to the noise to really understand the
world as it is you have to understand
not just what's going on today but what
has happened in the past as well just
screaming about imperialism or terrorism
doesn't change anything change takes
intellectual rigor not just outrage the
easiest thing you can do is use a
hashtag but it takes a lot more work to
really understand an issue and get
involved in a meaningful way this week
we're going to shift to a country which
is absolutely in the thick of the global
conversation right now but at the same
time is barely talked about Greece is
generally thought of as the world's
first democracy and currently finds
itself at the center of the global
financial crisis after several European
Union bailouts the most recent one
against the wishes of the people Greece
finds itself in a truly defining moment
will it forever be beholden to the
bankers in Germany
in Brussels or will it figure out a way
to reclaim its own financial
independence of course this financial
mess in the very country democracy was
born is set to the backdrop of the UK
leaving the EU and the brexit vote as
well as a massively shaken European
Union trying to deal with the migrant
crisis borders are blurred finances are
mixed and nobody seems to know how to go
forward when you add that to the rising
populist intern world we live in a time
when massive change is coming and the
question is what form will that change
take joining me to discuss all this is
economist and former greek Finance
Minister Yanis varoufakis Yanis was
instrumental in the fight against taking
the last EU bailout of 2015 and resigned
his post in the government when the
government accepted the money while his
economics are a big mix of influences
like leftist Karl Marx he found himself
shifting somewhat right like not wanting
to take the money during the lead-up to
the bailout which shows why traditional
labels even in the realm of economics
are becoming increasingly meaningless in
a world where tweet can cause a market
to go up or down our need to understand
how connected we are is getting more and
more important by the day what happens
in Greece no longer stays just in Greece
we're an interconnected world that at
times seems to be growing faster than we
can actually process if the UK leaves
the EU and if Greece is held hostage by
a bailout that it doesn't really want
what's the next Domino to fall and if
the EU continues to change how does that
not only affect countries like France
and Germany but the United States and
literally every other country on earth
as well through this connectivity many
of us are finding intellectual allies in
places we never thought that we would
have this is a beautiful thing if we can
take the time to understand a bit more
about history economics and philosophy
education is truly our only buffer
against the mistakes of the past if
history is doomed to repeat itself let's
at least try to make the repeats a
little less painful
[Music]
you